[Musica]
una donna di 27 anni è in procinto di
partorire
iniziano le prime contrazioni e 10 di
andare dal ginecologo per un controllo
la mente li il suo studio le idee un po
dalle acque a lei ti dicono che la
invito ad andare in ospedale
assicurandola che in tempi brevi sarebbe
arrivato anche lui nella notte la donna
ha dolori sempre più forti e chiedero
metrica perché non mi fate partorire
perché non mi aiuta in tram murray tanta
indifferenza
il ginecologo non arriva e l'ostetrica e
continuo andare dell'esatta la donna
lasciava zona chiusa in una stanza con
detto di pani disegnati sulle pareti
dopo 19 anni di sofferenza agli enti
decalogo per farla partorire
purtroppo però la donna non ha più le
contrazioni
nonostante tutto ciò a fatica dalla luce
una bambina di 2 chili e 9 nel viola
immobile non respira la mamma disperata
in commento a chiedere cosa successa la
mia bambina vi prego ditemi qual cosa
nessuno le risponde perché intende
rianimare la piccola pensate in
quell'ospedale non c'è nemmeno un
incubatrice
eppure quella bambina oggi ancora viva
nonostante stia affetta da una paralisi
debra infatti le quella donna e mia
mamma quella bambina sono io la mia vita
come avete potuto notare non è iniziata
col piede giusto
anzi mi sembra che tutto fosse stato già
scritto da quelle tre parole paralisi
celebrale infantile non è una malattia
ereditaria ma un disturbo neurologico c
è si presenta per cause imprevedibili
lungo come è successo a me per uno
scarso apporto di ossigeno durante la
nascita compromettendo la coordinazione
di tutti i movimenti del corpo in modo
irreversibile
i miei nuovi venti sono rigidi
scardinati tremolanti ma dal momento che
a voi piace guardare il bicchiere mezzo
pieno o mezzo vuoto
ti dava anche dei vantaggi in tutto
questo target è limite tutte le volte mi
dichiaro abitanti e inter gratis nei
musei
certo le file audio di un parcheggio
riservato e non solo quando cammino
scudetto così bene da fare il video del
team naomi campbell
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ho lottato per essere qui per essere la
donna ci sono oggi una donna
intraprendente coraggiosa libera capaci
di trasferirsi che andrà città pur di
realizzare i propri sogni
come potete immaginare non è stata
affatto semplice sin da piccola ho
dovuto fare tantissimo fisioterapia
logopedia non vedrà se vi come di di
controllo però se le vacanze estive
provare di provare sperimentare trovare
dei miei metri prima di riuscire a fare
qualsiasi cosa
ogni gesto che riuscirà a compiere anche
il più semplice come affidare un peluche
una penna era una grande vittoria per
nulla sconfitta sicuramente farsi in
merito va mia mamma che non si arresta
che non ha mai creduto nel parole dei
medici quando le hanno detto su io non
potrà parlare né tantomeno camminare
insomma i primi anni di vita sono stati
fondamentali per recuperare quanto più
autonomia possibile
col passare del tempo però mi sentivo
sempre più inadeguata sbagliata diversa
mi guardava allo specchio e odio ogni
centimetro del mio corpo mi chiedevo
perché si cosa perché perché sono così e
se avessi potuto sarei diventata
invisibile in work d'occhio ricorda
ancora quando sono stata invitata ad una
festa di compleanno
durante le superiori e come al solito un
paio di pantaloni nei laghi per
trascorrere il mio corpo alla mia mamma
quando mi ha vista mi ha detto figlio
dai perché stavolta non promettere una
gonna
dov'è carino non l'avessero fatto a
kasami scopriva la terza guerra mondiale
io continuo a tornare non voglio niente
stupito vestidello di come suona lo
talmente tanto che ad un certo punto
suonata la vicina perché di cosa stesse
succedendo in tutto questo non sono
mancati i duelli di compassione i
pietismi e coloro che mi devono mettere
limiti anche quando questi non c'è di un
po capitato che qualcuno decidesse per
voi che stabilisse cosa vedete cosa non
potete fare a me è successo è successo
quando un preside di un liceo non mi ha
ritenuto abbastanza abile per
frequentare la sua scuola è successo
quando all'università ne hanno detto
perché stai studiando tanto non può fare
questo tipo di lavoro è successo tante
volte ma sapete una cosa
quello è quelle parole mi hanno dato la
forza e la determinazione per dire si
vive si tu vuoi tu vuoi diplomati dopo i
laureati trovare qualsiasi cosa dei fili
si sono sì che di veramente
e così è stato vivo quindi posso ci sarà
sempre qualcuno li pronta sminuirli a
dirvi che non sarete capaci a fare
qualcosa non credeteci non fate
diventare i limiti le insicurezze mi
mettono gli altri i vostri limiti e le
cose in sicurezza perché sono voi siete
consapevoli di ciò che potete è di dio
che non potete fare voi è nessun altro
aveva all'incirca a 22 anni
quando ho scoperto di avere una malattia
degenerativa gli occhi che con il
passare del tempo potrebbe portarmi alla
cecità ciao gazzetta di vent'anni non è
abbastanza la paralisi delle gru
infantile è vero
avete ragione l'ho pensato anch'io ed
innegabile che questa malattia a chi
aggravata situazione ancora limitandovi
ancora di più
arrivato a questo punto hanno potuto
comincia lunedì non poter fare più nulla
o poi di angola che forse non valesse la
pena più continuare a vivere
ma se c'è la vita non puoi cambiare una
situazione
puoi cambiare il modo di cui ti fidi di
rispondere a quella situazione e di è
deciso che non mi sarei fatto fermare da
questo pensiero che non mi sarei
lasciata condizionale dagli eventi
neanche stavolta ho imparato così a
guardare il mondo con occhi sempre nuovi
ogni giorno a vivere dai miei conti due
gas come la sera in cui cercando di
essere romantica con il mio compagno io
ho detto guarda che bella luna stasera è
un po confuso mi ha risposto dove non lo
vedo come non lo è di più pulita odio
lui mi guarda e mi dice silvia si
riferisce a quella luce quella della
luna ma la luce di un lampione
vi lascio immaginare le dita a v giuro
che per me quella luna piena
nonostante tutte le difficoltà nella mia
testa c'è sempre stata la convinzione
non è fisso non si può così grande da
non potersi trasformare non posso ora
radunato tutta la negatività e tutti i
miei limiti per usarli come trampolino
di lancio per raggiungere i miei
obiettivi
volevo prendere la laurea specialistica
allora una vita professionale e poter
diventare perché no un punto di
riferimento per qualcuno pronto il punto
di riferimento candy pino mi sarebbe
servito per ricordarvi che nella vita
nulla impossibile vivo quindi posso
visto una bet
otto anni dopo sono qui su questo palco
a dirvi che sono riuscite a
specializzarmi in journalism occulto
l'editoriale non attorno il un per cento
di vista dopo aver trascorso giornate
dare tra libri e lenti d'ingrandimento
grazie a queste mani state scardinate ha
trasformato le mie passioni in una
professione diventata una scrittrice una
blogger una content creata ed infine la
ragazza timida cava paura di risposte
d'apparire oggi tra diventando un
esempio positivo per molte persone
attraverso i social o inizio da
raccontarmi ad usare la mia voce per
dare voce al fine di stilare e
sensibilizzare io scrivo cleo viaggio
mentre qualche un mondo che va oltre i
limiti che vedrà
ed è lo stesso buono per tutti voi io
non sono sola mia disabilità non sono
solo i miei limiti questi occhi un po
tolte queste strade tuo ci faccia lì
sono molto di più ho impiegato anni
prima di capire che non do vergognarmi
della mia diversita delle mie
imperfezioni e che quello vedere un
riflesso nello specchio non ha nulla di
sbagliato perché vedete tutti quanti
siamo diversi ed è proprio questa
diversita
adesso è la vera ricchezza il vero onore
al punto che contraddistingue ciascuno
di noi non il contrario
nel momento in cui ti rendi conto di
essere unico che nessuno al mondo è come
te che nessuno ha la tua stessa luce la
tua stessa determina altro fai finta
capisci di essere irripetibile e che la
vita ha infinite possibilità di offrirti
solo se glielo concerti sono grata della
mia vita e di ogni singolo mia conquista
trent'anni fa infatti quasi nessuno
avrebbe scommesso su di me ma io ho
imparato a prendermi cura di me
scegliendo l'amore al cos'è la rabbia a
gennaio mi limiti delle risorse e che a
venderli e se voglio posso fare
qualsiasi cosa
non esistono montagne troppo alto per
non essere scalate come non esistono
limiti dopo grandi da non essere
superati ed io lo so bene me ne ricordo
ogni volta che decide di andare a fare
trekking rosso per questi cambi che si
stancano e mi fanno perdere l'equilibrio
non ponetevi limiti non trovate scuse
per non vivere
desiderate al vetusti rio 20 fermarsi al
primo ostacolo o sembra in assoluto più
semplice ma non fatelo non sprecate in
questo modo il dono prezioso della vita
anche quando mi sembra di non avete
scelta piuttosto attrezzate la
meraviglia di essere vivi sperimentate
credete nelle vostre capacità per
seguite i vostri sogni e le vostre mete
abbiamo tutte le carte in regola per
fare di noi degli open dc capolavori
viviamo quindi possiamo grazie
[Applauso]